it's so interesting watching how
clickbait evolves on youtube because
then
there's this like anti-click bait meta
that i always see pop up
that eventually becomes the click bait
itself like i remember like
ages ago before like uh before like pro
zd
popularized the hey i don't give a [ __ ]
about clickbait it's just gonna be
my face and just like a very basic title
yeah with like no caps or whatever and
then that just became
the that became a whole genre of itself
because a video
with no clickbait and a [ __ ] ton of
views is clickbait yeah because
you're curious how did this get viewed
yeah this has to something's going on
here
right like if you saw like you know
like a video that had one of those like
indian facebook posts levels of editing
that had like 10 million views you'd
click on that [ __ ] because you're like
how the [ __ ] does this have 10 million
views yeah absolutely and then yeah
that's how it is that reminds me of
this the [ __ ] you were showing me like
yesterday
last thursday yeah i was sharing gone uh
have you seen uh
a dorman oh yeah i was showing god
darman and also
i don't get it i don't get it how is
this
got so many views god isn't into the
youtube desire so there's a channel
called darman
yeah and he i don't even know how to
describe it what is he he does these and
he
i swear it's so popular he does these
videos where
it's basically like a message like like
it's like motivational stuff
they'll be one where it's like gold
digger gets exposed or yeah
uh actor quits because he got hate
comment you know basically like
all right this guy gets a hate comment
online and then
darman comes in with a piece of
motivational advice that flips it all on
its head and the bullies feel like [ __ ]
and the guy the guy who was being
bullied gets a lamborghini succeeds in
life and it's always that it's like the
most stereotypical
man gets bullied or someone does bad
thing gets
gets the comeuppance for the bad thing
and the person who got did wrong
gets done right that's always how it is
like his videos just hit in like the
perfect or just
it's literally facebook i mean it is
facebook videos but it's even
it hits that uncanny value right where
it's just
so weird to watch one of the one of
these videos and just think
it's it's the most like bare bones
message that you can
that you can present in the video right
and the way i the way i
the way i thought of it watching these
videos that we're getting like
tens of millions of views by the way
it's it's like a
r slash that really happens post in
every video because every video ends
with
and then everyone collapsed you know
that's that's
what was the dude again on facebook
prince e
yeah like he kind of did like a similar
thing where he'd do like these like
beat poetry like too deep for you like
life lessons and i'm just like
no one lives there and then he did like
videos where he's like depression is
just sadness stop being sad
you did like videos like that yeah he
was like it's like depression is like
this tv remote it comes
then it goes yeah it comes then turn it
off
yeah it's terrible and then yeah and i
showed god i'm like yeah this guy gets
like 30 million views of video
yeah it's it's he uploads daily yeah
yeah which like
respect respect to him and his
production crew because the videos are
like very well shot yeah so very well
and they should be he's probably making
[ __ ] 50 million dollars a year
yeah yeah and you got like different you
know you've got so many different actors
playing these parts as well so you got
like a proper crew pumping these videos
out
um and i just think like you know it's
it's so
weird because there's so like there's so
few times where i watch a video
and i watch a trend on youtube and i'm
just like
i don't get it i don't i don't get it
like how is this doing
this well because sometimes you you see
a video and you're like okay
this isn't my type this isn't my type of
content but i can see why it's doing
well
yeah but then conor shows me this and
it's like the hottest [ __ ] trend
right now getting
[ __ ] blowing everyone out in terms of
views and i'm just like
how i don't know i mean it that's also
just really funny but
i mean i think it definitely also helps
the fact that there are a lot of
youtubers out there like poking the [ __ ]
out oh yeah the sony v
was just mocking you yeah so like that
in and of itself is just
free promotions people i guarantee
there's lots of people like hate
watching this [ __ ] it's so
preachy that you can't help but watch it
and think [ __ ] how like
it really ain't that deep it's like i've
[ __ ] seen disney movies less preachy
or yeah
yeah right right like like it's yeah
it's
it's it's fascinating i i found it like
fascinating
seeing that this was the hot thing
that's going on right now
i also showed him uh arcade cradiax if
you don't know what that is do you know
what that is no what's that it's the
guys that do the 3 am
a mangas bts meal video
what i totally hear it's honestly
impossible it doesn't sound like a real
video
well the point is is that they're
basically this channel that
parodies kid videos the 3 a.m videos
literally like five-year-olds
but including like adult jokes that kids
wouldn't get but also
mocking and parodying the style it's
really like it's the most internet humor
thing i've ever watched and it's so
funny
okay it's so good i don't even i can't
even explain it it's just like just
watch it
and you'll see it like arcade craniacs
arcade craniacs yeah and like they just
do a thing where it's like oh
i went to i went to get the bts meal and
then at 3am
and then bts jimin was delivered to my
door or something
and he like pronounced the name horribly
or something that's already funny and
then
he's like what is this and he drinks the
the sprite he's like
it's bts sweat i know i was at the
concert and it tastes like their sweat
and it's just like what is this it's
insane like it's and it's so popular
right now on youtube but it's so fun
what's going on with youtube recently
it's just so it's so insane obscure now
it's so good though i love where it's
going it's getting
so meta like everything is so meta right
now it's
i love it it's so funny if you haven't
checked it out um
yeah i kind of think you have to watch a
lot of youtube to enjoy it because
it's a parody on [ __ ] youtube that
adults wouldn't watch
but you would only know if you watched
videos that roasted the kids
the kids content anyway yeah or you've
seen the memes of it yeah it requires
like four layers of youtube knowledge to
enjoy but if you watch a [ __ ] ton of
youtube you might enjoy it okay
check it out it's a fever dream anyway
yeah it's very funny i think all of
what we've discussed right now has just
been a fever dream to me well we
but it's because i mean we live it we
watch it so much it's so relevant
when you show me i ended up staying up
like drunk till 4am watching his videos
being like what is going on why did i
watch them
it was after a little celebration to
open this office yeah yeah
and we went back and i was like let me
let me show you diamond
i just like my drunk foreign mind just
like could not comprehend what i was
watching
because it was it was like it was a
[ __ ] fever dream for me yeah yeah
yeah watch one darman video because i
can't it's so hard to explain what makes
it
weird i'll just i'll give you a quick
run-through of darman video right now
i'll do one it's like
all right hi i am cheating wife hi i am
husband with failing business
oh okay damn you're so gross poor
husband get away from me i'm gonna cheat
on you with someone
she cheats and then wow my business is
now succeeding cheating wife wants to
come back and and sleep with him again
but he's like no no i'm successful now
and happy in a relationship
moral of the story don't cheat on your
husband who is
working hard and being nice that's it
just common sense it's like it's just
yeah watch it it's funny
oh my god i mean i saw one about like
don't watch it alone get get a bunch of
your friends yeah
and then enjoy the the nature of it yeah
it's just so good yeah
i think i think i saw one that was like
against uh someone being
racist towards an um asian dad trying to
open a nail salon or something like that
right and i think the moral of the story
is
um don't be racist um and i was just
like
great i like the idea that somebody out
there who is
susceptible to a video changing their
whole view on racism
that they just watch this they're like
[ __ ] i've been racist this whole time
i can't believe this i should go and
apologize to the two asians i know in my
life
you know and it's like it's fine but
it's like you know you're out here
hustling i get it you know
that's easy to make money off of do it
[ __ ] it but it's not going to change
anyone's mind
i mean you know i appreciate the
sentiment because obviously you know
racism
is bad bad uh you know in case you
didn't know
um if you didn't know you should watch a
youtuber
you know but i was racist before darling
like every white man you know i was
going to cheat on my
you know boyfriend that was trying hard
to succeed in this business
but then i opened the fortune cookie
until i saw a dharma video it's
literally the fortune cookies on youtube
i was a gold digger before i met darma
i'm no longer a gold digger and i
appreciate everything in life